okay friends i'm having a
very very
something that i really want to share
with anyone who's listening
this is something worth journaling this
is an insight
worth having and
one that is actionable we often get told
by people that we must sacrifice the
present
for the future to live a responsible
life is to pay
your dues right to sacrifice the present
for the future the problem is that can
become systemic that can
that can metastasize into a pathology
whereby you always
sacrifice the present for the future
so that in the end you make yourself
sick because that
initial impulse while positive and
rational yeah sure
sacrifice some of the present for the
future so that you have
money for a rainy day and a roof over
your head and
food in the fridge i get that but
but when sacrificing
when sacrificing the present for the
future becomes pathological
what is needed is an intervention
that disrupts that pattern and shakes
that snow globe
so what became clear to me today is that
sometimes
the neurotic actually needs to sacrifice
the future for the present
that may be the healing of our trauma
the healing of our fractures must come
from casting away the confines of the
self the super ego and monkey mind and
worrying mind
and the responsible thinker that
sacrifices the present for the future
but has become
pathological an over-vigilant
hyper-vigilant
ego that has turned into a tyrant and
perhaps the only prescription
the solution is actually to disrupt
and to sacrifice the future for the
present to live without consequence
if only for a moment to take the trust
fall and live with romantic abandon and
give away all your money and quit
the job and take a journey across the
world right to leave it all behind like
the christian parables that say he who
must save his life
must first lose it and so the answer to
the question at times my friend
i think is the blissfuck the full
submission the full
surrender the surrender of our
affordances to sacrifice the future for
the present
the time is now and action is required
and tomorrow doesn't matter anymore
that's when you're willing to die
to the here and now because if you
cannot submit you cannot die
and if you cannot die you cannot be
reborn this death
practice means exactly this the future
must be sacrificed
for the present as we hurl ourselves
into the abyss
and realize that it's a feather bed a
trust fall an artist on stage who hurls
himself into his audience and into his
art is also
sacrificing the future for the present
for he's putting it all
on this moment all the chips are on the
table he's giving his
entire life to this moment he cares not
if he survives it for what survives will
not be him anyway no one survives
a real conversation no one survives a
real encounter of the kind that asks for
nothing less than everything
so if you've been told your whole life
and if you've been pathologized to think
that the present must continuously be
sacrificed for the future friends
i say you the healing the solution to
your problem the problem to be
solved will be that becomes the problem
that solves
you is precisely this
oh no i can't be in the present because
i have to worry about tomorrow well no
guess what
you don't have to spend the present
worrying about tomorrow you don't have
to sacrifice the present for the future
in fact what you need friends
is to sacrifice the future for the
present
enough to die you have to die jamie
wheel said it enough to die
and be reborn and by dying i mean the
trustful i mean the pilgrimage
he who must save his life must first
lose it
you must get lost
to become found
uh